yeah unfortunately this this did
conflict with Ally chest-high lorina
which i think is still going on so I was
put in a tough spot I figured that there
will be many more titled arenas they
actually put out a schedule for the next
several months then it's not you often
that I'll play like a a slower more
serious tournament with a lot of strong
players so thought this would be a nice
way to to mix things up cowboy triple to
seven and just flagged flags opponent
with only a pawn very dirty I hope you
didn't learn that from me I'll take no
responsibility penguin is playing both
that's so great
I forgot that I could potentially sign
mole if you like only penguin is penguin
is one of the few people on the planet
capable of of doing that okay Oh Joyner
this person is this camel I know this
person okay I forgot what he plays
anyway um again goodbye chat and hello
chess let's play time on us during these
games no no chat just commentary chat
can interact with themselves if you're
watching in the future on YouTube you
can say hi to the the twitch chat yeah
g3 g3 is an annoying line there's a
couple of things I can play I complain I
have 6 H 5 I can play each 5 right away
I can play d6 Bishop d7 I think I'll
stick with will I used to play which is
this there should be seven
I think Bishop e7 9 f6 and just try and
play a what do we call this shoving
ingen when the pawns are here not quite
a hedgehog or a hippo and I there's some
reason why the bishop goes to d7 before
the kingside develops which
I think involves something with dealing
with 95 ideas I thought rookie one
there's some rookie 195 idea okay this
looks looks kind of reasonable a Forza
move so I want to play Knight of six
always have to watch out for a five I
don't think it's too dangerous
this takes takes e5 looks completely
fine sometimes white wants to play g4
the issue with g4 is that I can take and
play e5 and GeForce hanging so might be
three makes some sense
no no why h5 is sticking out
there's also 95 here high fives very
typical that kind of gives away central
control so if I can so the counseling is
of course a main move I want to play
that I have to watch out for a g4 so
castling g4 I don't I can't take on on
d4 there and e5 probably runs into some
ninety five idea maybe it's playable
though it's imagine castling g45 if
takes I think I can maybe I can't okay
if it takes I just say with night and if
g4 or a g5 Knight g5 there's Knight d5
which is annoying there so because of
that I might just play Knight a5
which kind of maybe it doesn't allow me
five it's play Knight a5 and this poses
a bigger question to white so there's a
few ideas with this move one idea I want
to play Knight c4 and hits things which
are not defended the only two things
which are undefended in White's position
the other idea is because I was low on
space my mind adhesives were a bit
cramped so
I might want to trade off nights I'm
also freeing the c6 word for the bishop
which would then create the g7 square
for my knight so trying to achieve some
kind of peace harmony
I'm also unleashing the C file so it's
very common to play like rook c8 b 599
c4 if i castled I feel like White's
player would have been too easy on the
King side okay so the Queen was selected
there wow so I guess if it's like if
it's highlighted yellow like this it's
selected if I click again it doesn't do
[ __ ] what if I right-click no it's still
selected so how they do you select
without like you just click a random
pawn mm-hmm can I click off the board
wait off the board
no okay trying to minimize these
click-click disasters anyway yeah it's
taking a think this is another streamer
I don't know if he's streaming though
I'm actually kind of happy I didn't go
with this yeah I have been playing this
h5 each four line but it's a lot riskier
okay so let's take I think my c4 was too
too much of an annoyance for white but
I'm happy to get the trade queenie queen
being on a5 also prevents ePHI from
happening
and I still have ideas of like rook c8
what else to do
rook c8 b5 how castling probably makes
more sense
u5 is also an idea
u5 is kind of double-edged because it
weakens d5 but fixes upon here might
make more sense when the bishops here so
Queen e2 interesting h5 is also some
idea of H 5 H 3 probably not so useful
I think rook c8 s very natural I am kind
of delaying castling but I'm figuring
that my rooks going to see a regardless
there's no immediate reason why I should
Castle and there might be some probably
not right away but imagining some idea
of taking Bishop e5
like if the knight moves anywhere like
91 dumb move then Bishop e5 wins
material
I'm trying to like deselect a piece this
is really annoying maybe this and then
this
no hmm okay not too important here I
just have to not click an empty square
yeah so I'm trying to predict White's
next move might be something like rook a
d1 and then like be b5 before but be
five blocks a the rink and then probably
allows me five so I'm probably just
castling and see what white is up to
there are ideas of just like just
stacking the exchange like takes takes
and then maybe it's more typical in the
dragon how effective it would be the
main reason to sack the exchange would
be if I can somehow win the e4 pawn
wowie five so trying to make me regret
that I'm not casting probably have to
take I mean trying to figure out the
idea takes takes takes there is Bishop
takes be seven or a copy AIDS
there's no bishop at for because I take
on you too and then and do things I
guess White's winning a six but that I
wouldn't be too so there's we trade on
e5 I lose this pawn rook b8 this should
take say six rook takes B - that just
looks very pleasant like the likes red
Bishop would get out of play for whites
oh there's good takes here by the way
but doesn't happen
trying to be extra careful my Queens
like wide open but there's no like the
bishops on a dark square so there's no
random Bishop checks to win the Queen if
the King was on d8 then there'd be
Bishop e6 check so rook b8 so Bishop f4
kind of defends but it's like rock beats
yeah so there's about four right I take
and then when the Bishop Bishop takes a
six I think I can get away with this
because it might would be hanging in
White's pieces just don't seem so well
coordinated there and time is very good
as well I think white was was definitely
trying to punish me because I didn't
Castle and now the like all these files
are open for whites but black has
initiative so I'm not sure not sure what
my opponent was thinking okay so rook
takes b2 just looks great yeah I'm
looking for whites resources but the
knight will be attacked
as queen d3 may be expected in queen d3
you swing d3 makes sense or Queen d2
very similar so it's material I'm up up
upon yeah Queen d2 me it gets a bit
weird so there's a few moves that come
to mind
there is my g4 and there's Bishop c5
there's castling of course a bishop d4
is probably a threat actually Bishop d4
I have Bishop c5 so maybe it's not a
threat alright Eric Rosen with the
Sicilian Kings still in the center
fortuitous on the King side what does
that mean uh what just happened some
weird server glitch so probably castling
okay you wanted all right good for rosin
go rosin only the finest streamers play
counseling okay d1 Queen c7 a simple
chess
I should note I'm not worried about this
because why would have too many things
hanging mr. d4 so yeah Bishop c5 is my I
go to move a nice kind of defensive
slash offensive resource and this just
facilitates trades if takes takes keen
each one still have to be a bit careful
ideally I'd like to stay on the
offensive
I play Brooke rook c8 9 a 4 is
off-limits because it Bishop if rook
takes f6 I assume Queen takes here Queen
takes d7 takes yeah I'd just be up the
exchange there
so leaving some tension so there's a
cool move rook takes situ here don't
know if it works oh cuz takes takes King
here takes and then bishops a bit loose
maybe it does work though I don't know I
mean there's takes takes takes I'm up
two pounds there Eric Rosen is crushing
his opponent once again it's fortuitous
four against two Eric Rosen's winning so
much he thinks he's playing me
no you're somebody else can't believe
I'm winning
there's also very simple just trade on
d4 and win c2 that might be the way to
go because the Knights attacked and the
Knights very restricted have nine moves
on the pawns weak my moves there's also
Bishop e5 ideas yeah let's just take
twice rook takes c2 would have been a
bit more flashy but I like this line
it's amazing like these squares all
these squares are I mean II four is
accessible but then I'm happy to trade
more each is off-limits on these squares
don't look so appealing okay so 94 there
should be five there should be five
doesn't quite work because white takes
with check but let's just take
I'm with Henrik 67 I mean that's
probably the way to go and I can move
back yeah actually
Rick Kings t7 okay never mind more than
182 in the end now Bishop oh wow
Oh both things are hanging thankfully I
have rook c7
I forgot the bishop attacks backwards
okay that's it's very fortunate the
otherwise I would have been losing
material there so it's gonna fight
some kind of
Bishop CEO Bishop d6 doesn't it look so
great you rook c8
just want to facilitate trades and peace
activity is very important in these
positions time is also very important
try and keep a a time advantage rook c1
let's label should be five first Bishop
e7 things get a bit you're a bit weird
the Bishop e7 check here I should
probably throw in the check
yeah Chuck there's no Roxy to his Bishop
f1
it's weird it's getting very weird
but ding everything kind of defends each
other high-fives a move
g6 also
uh-uh what to do
by five
it looks so weakening but it's almost
meeting let's try this time is skin this
is what my opponent wanted to complicate
matters get into some time scramble
thinking there should be one measured b5
looks questionable though
there should be seven so look see to
check let's see three also possible
start with this
oh wait Kim here here here in the knee
five the fork I was looking for meeting
ideas but if you five a better work
you have three so I could
I don't have you know II five it's also
G five here
so close
[Music]
Jake's takes I should just play simple
let's check in and move here
I'll simplify there's gonna be some
endgame time scramble I'm in control
time is very close now it's just like a
bullet game I am up to pawns here I
might be losing a pawn back okay Brooke
g7 I can train
yeah I think whites just running out of
ideas it's taking this I wrote got three
just force mates
hey g5 mate let's get some g5 emotes g5
almost unstoppable or a five I mean
there's Rick f7 unexpected meeting that
ended really quickly I'm so disappointed
he didn't let me play g5 mate that's
okay nice game